[Applaudissements]
ah bon avant que je mens prennent plein
la gueule parce qu'avec ce mikado humain
je voudrais dire que laetitia milot
laetitia je trouve que tu es une
comédienne encore formidable vraiment à
chacun un téléfilm c'est un carton c'est
mérité vraiment je t'adore
je peux plus extrêmement bien tout s'est
tu et humaine de mai comédienne préférée
et regarder ça sur france 3 ils sont
très très bons en télé l'air super
thriller sur france3 connaissait alors
voici fumant mais dans la gueule je ne
jure que je ne mets pas ta bande annonce
avant un petit mois du moins certains de
mes amis le début est beaucoup trop
facile prenez-en une d'hier ait sera non
non non non non non non résistons pour
le missile
ce thème est les prends celui en direct
mavericks ravasi faux pas mais non c'est
sûrement un attentat il ya quelqu'un qui
gagne et qui perd oui tu attends
laetitia n'est pas venu pour gagner mais
uniquement pour arroser serré mais je
vous dis ça gagne je remets sa
bande-annonce attend qu'on s'attaque à
gagner la fia avait on y va comment ce
commentaire
chacun son tour tiré cette fois tombé de
gaulle ballon tombe
voilà un point pour laetitia c'est
facile elle est un extrait dec
le dossier va faire semblant ne pas
vouloir faire tomber les ballons pour ça
un partout où elle met dedans la lancer
en premier c'est moi qui vais arriver en
premier au ballon de ascension continue
rapidement vas-y stade etc répondant à
ça fait combien pour l'instant de deux
par deux à 2 alors ones à partir d'un
qu'ils avaient cédé le vétéran le déchet
la regarde elle sert à rien et à partir
de là ça va commencer par perez en syrie
mais si je claquais leur prépare toi
un caire qu'il faut que j'en ai à partir
de là ça va être compliqué à partant de
là ouais tiens tiens vas-y vas-y attend
non elle est ici est vraiment venu pour
gagner c'est à dire qu'il prend le trou
et briatte oasis a day pour l'instant
employables 5 à 4 si la vie tiens on est
celui-là on est celui-là
ils veulent que je prenne le micro parce
que ça va partir je crois on veut garder
là bas attention moi c'est la prochaine
je crois que c'est la prochaine on met
une étiologie c'était parti n'est que le
mica douche un jeu qui à fait conscient
11 - fait partie
zitte sur le tir le non cumul avec tu
peux y avait du brouillard et de piller
les trient les familles on a tu peux
lire c'est bon on ne va pas tomber sur
la d 6 mois c'est plus facile aux images
issa dcti relatant vas-y vas-y c'est mon
fond
valbuena 6 avec lula il savait papa avec
le premier
[Applaudissements]
j'hésite moi même pas s'ils savaient
qu'ils savaient que tire aussi retiré
tout voilà encore une fois encore une
fois la chose pour ce pont royal est bon
vendredi à vous le week-end
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais